military jets flew in formation over the
marble monuments of Washington DC and
over a hospital in Baltimore in a
symbolic salute to doctors nurses
hospital workers and others on the front
lines fighting the pandemic
despite the ceremony health workers in
many parts of the country say shortages
of personal protective equipment
continue in a hopeful sign for hard-hit
New York City the last kovat 19 patients
were discharged from a convention center
that had been converted into an
emergency hospital the Javits Center
treated more than 1,000 people with the
disease and the US Navy hospital ship
comfort its services no longer needed
sailed out of New York Harbor
despite the glimmerings of Hope New York
Governor Andrew Cuomo said the virus
continues to steal hundreds of lives in
the state each and every day that number
has remained obnoxiously and
terrifyingly high and it's still not
dropping at the rate we would like to
see a drop in California where Governor
Gavin Newsom has ordered all beaches
closed protesters complained about not
being able to swim sunbathe and surf
they're in the minority a new poll shows
70% of California residents approve of
Newsom's actions in controlling the
pandemic while President Trump headed
off to Camp David for the weekend the
White House announced late Friday that
it would replace the government
Inspector General who wrote a critical
report on the Trump administration's
response to the outbreak the report said
the administration failed to coordinate
distribution of desperately needed
medical equipment well I think it's a
beginning after seeking to stifle
criticism from non partisan experts fits
a pattern of behavior for drunk the data
shows he has also refused to allow the
government's chief infectious disease
expert dr. Anthony foul G to testify
before come
of the Democratic controlled House of
Representatives next week
Rob Reynolds al Jazeera